hi there steve
here steve kaufman
and today i want to talk about the
subjunctive in spanish and other what i
call language habits
the reason i'm doing this is because i
made a video in spanish a couple of
weeks ago
and one of the viewers here a spanish
speaker
came on to correct me which is fine
pointing out that i got the subjunctive
wrong
on a couple of occasions
and also that i said la sistema instead
of el sistema systema although it enz
other words of greek origin
are often masculine all right
they're both part of the same phenomenon
and that is this first of all with
regard to the spanish subjunctive
you can google today and you can find
umpteen websites that will give you a
detailed explanation of when to use the
subjunctive and what the endings are in
the different verbs and the regular
verbs and so forth and so on
i just looked at one it had like eight
different situations where you use the
subjunctive
and then it had
tables of endings and stuff like that
i think it's pretty well impossible to
remember that when you are speaking when
you go to use the language
you can't possibly think is this one of
the eight situations that requires this
objective
i think it's important to be aware that
there is a subjunctive in spanish and
french and italian and even in english i
wish i were is the subjunctive the
subjunctive basically is a
change in the form of a verb reflecting
the fact that there is some wishing some
uncertainty some obligation
that kind of thing so it's not as
straight this is it's i wish this were
so this uncertainty surrounding the verb
causes the verb to change in a number of
languages
but
how do we and and so okay so that's
that's what the subjunctive is in
general terms you can please do your own
search to look for more specific rules
rules which i have looked at many many
times
and yet i continue to make mistakes
why
because language is a matter of habit
and you can lose a habit
you can if i'm
surrounded by spanish content and
spanish-speaking people and reading a
lot in spanish the likelihood that i
maintain the sort of spanish habit is
greater when i am not in that situation
where i don't have you know the
opportunity to hear
read speak spanish
i tend to revert back to
habits from my own language that are
more you know
strongly ingrained in me
uh and that's normal
i mean i often make the case that uh
you know you hear german people say
i have lived in canada since many years
because that's the german structure
uh and and many swedish people say it is
many people in china instead of there
are because that's the swedish structure
yet if we are surrounded by the language
we start if we are open to the language
we start to pick up on the way people
are speaking around us and we recover
some of these habits but to get
something like the subjunctive right you
actually have to develop that as a habit
now reading the rules may help but
you'll you'll you'll very quickly forget
what you've what you've read there
another thing about these habits and
about
correct language habits
and let's just digress learning out of
the language is actually acquiring
cultural habits linguistics habits of
another
group
so you have to be open to receiving
these influences to allow them to
penetrate your brain so to speak but the
fact that you get something like the
subjunctive right
once several times for a period of time
doesn't mean that you will always get it
right it's the same if you play tennis
even your serve goes in sometimes and
sometimes the serve doesn't go in
the fact that you get it right doesn't
mean you won't get it wrong later on and
vice versa the same is true with
masculine and feminine now i
when i come to a word in spanish where
i'm aware that this is a greek origin
word it's somewhere in my brain that
tells me i'm making a special effort to
use the masculine but you're going to
get some of those wrong and that's the
same with people learning french you
know the whole gender thing you can't
possibly go through all your words and
rules for which is feminine which is
masculine you have to develop that as a
habit you have to have these phrases
that naturally come out of your
brain
and we do develop the habits for example
in spanish
we say me gusta like everyone who has
any knowledge of spanish has no trouble
saying me gusta which is like like right
which is not at all similar to english
but we use it so often so often it
becomes ingrained as a habit the
subjunctive is also a habit that we have
to acquire
but uh it doesn't come up as often
so um
you know uh i and this is not just the
subjunctive it's verbs of motion in
slavic languages or cases or tones in
chinese or all of these different things
that are sort of um
structures or ways of speaking you know
polite forms in japanese
these are are things that we have to get
used to and we can fall out of habit if
we aren't
surrounded by the language and when when
we go back to a situation where we're
using the language and hearing the
language and speaking it and reading it
we tend to our level improves
and then of course when we're away from
it the level can
you know deteriorate decline
and some things just simply don't get
corrected and uh
even native speakers for example lots of
native speakers in french don't use the
subjunctive correctly
and it's funny the subjunctive becomes
one of these sort of traps that teachers
like i uh i read somewhere that in order
to get your bilingual bonus as an
anglophone
uh
you know
public servant in canada if you work for
the government they offer you a
bilingual bonus
so if people couldn't get the
subjunctive right they wouldn't get
their bilingual bonus which of course is
absolutely ridiculous because it's quite
possible to communicate very effectively
to understand what is said to get your
meaning across
all without using the subjunctive lots
of native speakers do it they also and
we see this in english there are forms
that are gradually falling out of favor
a lot of people don't say if it were
they they say if it was and they don't
say to whom they say to who so it's
possible that the subjunctive will
evolve or that in certain situations
people no longer use the subjunctive so
that to use this as a
criterion for determining you know uh
bilingual bonuses in the canadian public
service is just ridiculous however we
all would like to sound as elegant as
possible in the language we are learning
that means we want to be accurate we
want to
basically conform to what is considered
correct usage
and if we want to get better at the
spanish subjunctive
or gender or anything else we simply
need a lot of exposure to the language
listening reading speaking writing
the more ways in which we interact with
the language if we are open to what's
happening in the language we will
gradually up our game improve
we may out of curiosity
go and check up the rules that affect
the subjunctive and in fact i think it's
a good thing to do
no question that
this viewer of mine pointing out that i
made some mistakes with subjunctive
makes me a little more you know aware of
the subjunctive and so i'm going to be a
little more careful i'm going to watch
for it more when i listen and read and
when i speak i'm going to make a little
greater effort to make sure that i get
the subjunctive right
more often than wrong
and hopefully that way
develop some good habits but it won't be
overnight and i can get it right once
and wrong the next time
but the main thing is to communicate so
there you have it
uh
my take on the spanish subjunctive and
other language habits
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you